die jungs haben nämlich auf höhe 13 nach
la paz geformt das ist ein fehler wenn
man auf höhe 13 kein lapis finden kannst
rss feeds und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge war oh kommentare
heute habe ich für euch wieder drei
folgen ausgesucht drei der heutigen
aktuellen folgen und die für euch
kommentiert eigentlich ist drei plus
eins denn ich habe noch ein kleines
detail zu einer vierten fast folge
reingepackt aber was das ist wenn dir
gleich sehen als allererstes sagen wir
mal um welche folgen es sich heute
drehen wird das sind die folgen von
thieme zickzack diesen wir dabei team
aus it auch die wieder am start wie der
letzten folge und der neue und dritte im
bunde ist team erste folge tod also luca
congo after und hallodri die habe ich
auch mit reingenommen ausschütte wisse
ja dass ist nur noch hautnah nach dem
wenig gestorben ist und im zickzack
wenigen brasilia das dürfte aber in
diesen tagen so ziemlich jeder wissen
denn die jungs haben ja ähnlichen hype
das kleine detail die plus1 folge ist
noch eine anmerkung zu teams expert denn
die haben heute ein kleines detail
rausgehauen allerdings zu diesem
zeitpunkt durch das aufnehme das ist
jetzt ungefähr um 8 uhr haben die ihre
ware folge noch nicht raus kommen bzw
ich hatte noch keine gelegenheit mehr
die anzuschauen fleck kam zum 8 uhr aus
das kann sein aber lasst uns als aller
erstes mal auf team zickzack eingehen
wir haben in ihrer heutigen folge echt
gut treffer gelandet mit enchantment und
zwar haben die eine feier aspect
enchantment auf an eisenstadt bekommen
und haben sich damit ein ziemlich
ziemlich ziemlich gutes schwert gebaut
welches das ist und welche anderen
entscheiden doch darauf hin dass seht
ihr in der ersten folge dass der erste
link in der beschreibung des täters ist
der fünfte folge der erste link und in
der beschreibung ich habe euch wie immer
die folgen verlinkt über die fehde führt
zur folge von webers tiefe die die noch
nicht gesehen haben da seht ihr unter
anderem welches entscheidenden die da so
haben ja was bedeutet das jetzt
eigentlich fire is back entscheiden das
bedeutet dass die personen die mit dem
spät getroffen wird das sagt jetzt nur
für alle die nicht direkt wissen was
facebook bewirbt anfängt zu brennen ich
glaube bei einem feuer aspect 1
enchantment sind das zwei ticks ich habe
es aber nicht sie nicht nachgeschaut 2
ticks heißt ca ein herz je nachdem wie
der schaden durch die rüstung reduziert
wird glaubt er kann auch nicht reduziert
werden kann dass wahrscheinlich
weniger sein aber prinzipiell sind zwei
ticks also tick tick und ein herz weg
das ist im kampf sehr sehr viel hamann
während man den gegner schlägt und
gerade bei den längeren kämpfen geht man
sehr viele hits der gegner einfach
konstant brennt die ganze zeit und sich
löschen muss und da hat man die
möglichkeit dem 1 2 hitzel den rücken zu
geben dass es eine gute sache
allerdings funktioniert das nicht bei
regen das heißt bei kämpfen im regen
bietet eine feier spd hat keinen vorteil
es sei denn man ist irgendeiner höhle
und es regnet in der höhle nicht dann
wie es auch in höhlen rechnet aber dann
funktioniert der effekt dann doch wieder
die haben auch einen mops porno bei sich
für early das nicht bemerkt haben das
ist ein extrem großer vorteil denn so
können sie sich das level fahren zum
beispiel im netz das mit einem gewissen
risiko verbunden ist oder aber mit
langjährigem einen ganz gut sparen und
können einfach die ganze warten bis sie
bei ihnen da die zombies pon das ist
echt ne gute sache da haben sich die
position ihrer base gut ausgewählt oder
können sie sich gerade auch viel zeit
sparen denn das zeitmanagement des
echten faktor der wirklich wichtig ist
in den wahren folgen
das weiß ich auch noch von dem projekt
legend was die firma gemacht habe aber
das ist ein anderes
dann kommen wir zum thema taktik von
zickzack denn die jungs haben gesagt sie
möchten sich eisenstädter machen und die
dias für rüstung aufsparen
dazu habe ich ein bisschen recherchiert
und ich heute auch grabmal micro okay
warum es ist ein sich eine gute taktik
ist zu befürworten denn dazu möchte
jetzt mal ein paar fakten auf den tisch
legen so weit ich das kann ich habe dazu
im kurs ein bisschen recherchiert
eine eisen rüstung bringt 60 prozent
schadens reduktion also 60 prozent des
einkommens schadens werden von der eisen
rüstung absorbiert die die rüstung
allerdings absorbiert 80 prozent des
schadens wohlgemerkt beiden verzaubert
dagegen wissen wir dass ein eisen
schwert mit sharps 5 nur ein schadens
punkt weniger macht als ein dia schwert
mit sharp 15 also man kann das schon an
der relation erkennen dass die dias
umrüstung deutlich besser investiert
sind und man braucht einfach auch extrem
extrem viele dias um 15 die schwer zu
bekommen und die die es neben deutlich
wieder zu bekommen als eisen das ja auch
klar
deswegen ist diese taktik an sich ganz
gut ist auch zu empfehlen
das mit den germans ist so eine sache
das ist relativ tricky
da gibt es so genannte apps fekters
regulieren wie weit das protection
enchantment den schaden reduziert als
ich jetzt nur auf allgemeine protection
of fire protection und pipapo
wir wollen es aber nicht so nötig machen
was hier allerdings auf der seite steht
darauf gestoßen wenn das ganz
interessant ist dass bereits mit zwei
protection vier teilen und einem
protection einst teil der maximale
schutz effekt von 25 ps erreicht ist und
das quasi alle rüstungsteile die dann
noch dazu gefügt werden beispielsweise
noch ein protection vier teilen dritte
style oder aber dass all das andere teil
nicht auf art action einzel sondern auch
vier sind unnötig und denn effekt wird
nicht mit einbezogen und die wirklich
also können wir das quasi schenken
das habe ich hier gesehen alle pvp
experten unter euch können ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben
ob das 1 1 87 immer noch so ist oder ob
das auf eine alte version zutrifft okay
dann springe man weiter zu team aus shit
die haben in ihrer heutigen folge
offengelegt dass sie wohl ehses
koordinaten observiert haben sich
irgendwie seine koordinaten ausgerechnet
haben
aus irgendeinem aus irgendeiner zeile
das könnt ihr kommentar noch mal
erklären wie das geht das weiß ich
selbst auch nicht
scheinbar hat er nicht seine richtigen
xy koordinaten offengelegt eric scott
colley hat meine ich sondern irgendwie
irgendwas anderes daraus haben sie sich
errechnet meinten sie zumindest sie
haben sie auf jeden fall auf die jagd
nach asse gemacht und wenn ich lisa dann
ist das immer hautnah da bin ich schon
raus ist und haben auch tatsächlich
seine höhle gefunden was allerdings in
der höhle passiert ist das seht ihr in
deren folge das ist der link nummer zwei
in der beschreibung dann haben sie sich
auch noch zwei dinge gesucht und dazu
könnte ich auch nochmal zwei fakten
rausholen die ich selbst auch nicht
wusste davor also ich lerne auch etwas
fester bei im zuge dieses projekts und
zwar haben sie sich noch lapis und äpfel
gesucht und la paz und äpfel sind
besondere gegenstände
denn
die findet man nicht so leicht wie man
denkt die jungs nämlich auf höhe 13 nach
love is geformt das ist ein fehler weil
man auf höhe 13 kein lapis finden kann
denn lapis findet man zum meisterteam
minecraft wiki nur zwischen den höhen
fünf und elf
das heißt auch für 13 kann man gar kein
labs finden und da man ja auf 413 steht
auch keins sehen durch abbauen würde man
jetzt aufhört 12 stehen käme man
vielleicht noch drauf aber für 13
sinkt die chance schon also alle dealer
besuchen zwischen 5 und 11 suchen und
die äpfel zu dem thema das musste ich
auch gar nicht
man kann äpfel scheinbar nur von eichen
und schwarz zeichen erhalten also man
bekommt von akazien keine äpfel
man bekommt von burton keine äpfel und
von allen sonstigen bäumen auch keine
äpfel scheinbar nur von eichen und
schwarz eichen und das mit einer
jeweiligen drop chance von einem 210
also 05 pro block und da so ein baum
aber extrem viele laub blöcke hat müsste
sich das potenzial das heißt immer so
ein stammen abbaut und man hat dann um
20 laut blöcke die die spawnen dann
würde sich die chance
entsprechend erhöhen das ist aber
stochastik ist ist eine andere sache so
dann kommen wir damit schon zu team drei
erste folge tod
die jungs sind ja dafür bekannt dass sie
wild haben er lud der spitze ich hasse
ihn so sehr hat in der ersten folge sich
einfach senkrecht runter gebaut am spawn
zwar auch schon eine box taktik muss man
sagen
dadurch sind sie aber jetzt ein bisschen
hinten dran wenn man das mit anderen
teams vergleich die von fire aspect
enchantment ein solches an chapman hatte
übrigens auch weiß weiß schon erfolge
vorher glaube ich hab so schnell folge
drei oder vier können auch mal
nachschauen
die sache ist luca also komm crafter
hatte zu beginn der folge nummer 53
rüstungs punkte und hallodri 01 punkte
wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe das
heißt die jungs war ein bisschen hinten
dran haben aber im zuge der fünften
folge ein bisschen gas gegeben und sich
um ihre rüstung gekümmert wie sie dann
am ende da standen rüstungs technischen
was sie alles gefunden haben seht ihr
wieder in deren folge das ist der link
nummer drei
und sie haben auch noch eine ganz nette
kleinigkeit in deren folge gefunden
wie sag mal wie kann man zum schreiben
eine art natürlich generierte struktur
sagt er sich welche struktur das ist
aber eine recht nützliche die haben das
ist glaube ich zumindest hier sind nicht
ganz dahinter gekommen aber auf jeden
fall eine gute sache für jede haben ein
bisschen glück gehabt das gönne ich den
auch und jetzt kommen wir zum fans
reichlich zur info plus eins das ist die
zum team steckt die schon angekündigt
hat und zwar haben die jungs heute in
ihrer aufnahme die falle erklärt die sie
gestern in ihrer ware folge vier mann
ist habe ich gestern gebaut haben die
heutige folge 5 war zumindest zu dem
zeitpunkt wo ich das ja aufnehmen es
noch nicht online die konnte ich noch
nicht anschauen
deswegen kommt teams expert auch bisher
noch nicht vor allem ware kommentare
allerdings kann sich das für ein ändern
wenn die mal früher hochladen oder ich
zeitreisen maschine oder sowas bekommen
sowie das ding von hermine granger das
ding noch mal mit dem die zeit
zurückdrehen kann man auf jeden fall das
war's von heutigen folge varro
kommentare danke übrigens noch einmal
fürs mikrofon bauen und für die
anmerkungen die mir bei der letzten
folge gemacht hat das war echt cool
wir sind bei der nächsten folge wieder
haut rein macht's gut und check
natürlich die folgen und einer
beschreibung